las estaturas de un grupo de estudiantes
tienen una distribución normal con una
media de 150 centímetros y una
desviación estándar de 20 centímetros
daniel es un estudiante y tiene una
estatura de 160 y 1.4 centímetros cuál
es la proporción de las estaturas
menores a la de daniel pensemos en lo
que nos están pidiendo nos dicen que las
estaturas tienen una distribución normal
así que tienen una forma parecida a ésta
tiene una media de 150 centímetros que
está por aquí y nos dicen que tiene una
desviación estándar de 20 centímetros
danielle tiene una estatura de 160 y 1.4
centímetros así que su estatura está por
encima de la media digamos que está más
o menos por acá
y nos pregunten cuál es la proporción de
las estaturas menores a la de daniel
queremos encontrar esta área bajo la
curva normal pues nos dará la proporción
de las estaturas menores que la estatura
de danielle les voy a dar una pista de
cómo hacer esto tenemos que encontrar
cuántas desviaciones estándar por encima
de la media se encuentra la estatura de
danielle y podemos hacerlo porque nos
dicen cuál es la desviación estándar
además de que sabemos cuál es la
diferencia entre la estatura de danielle
y la media una vez que encontremos
cuántas desviaciones estándar está por
encima de la media que es nuestro
puntaje z
podemos buscar en la tabla z cuál es la
proporción menor a esta cantidad en esta
distribución normal vamos a hacerlo aquí
tengo mi emulador de la calculadora de
84 la estatura de danielle es de 160 y
1.4 la media es 150 la resta nos da 11.4
centímetros cuántas desviaciones
estándar está esto por encima de la
media nos dicen que para esta
distribución la desviación estándar es
20 centímetros así que tomamos 11.4
nuestra respuesta anterior y la
dividimos entre 20 lo que nos da 0.57
podemos decir que esto está 0.57
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media para qué nos sirve esto podemos
tomar este puntaje z y buscarlo en una
tabla zeta para encontrar cuál es la
proporción que es menor a 0.57
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media vemos esta tabla zeta y vamos a
buscar este puntaje z en ella esta
primera columna de la tabla nos dice el
puntaje z
hasta las décimas y estas otras columnas
nos indican la cantidad de las
centésimas de este puntaje en 0.57
tenemos un 5 en la posición de las
décimas así que elegimos este renglón y
tenemos un 7 en la posición de las
centésimas así que vamos a elegir esta
columna
esta cantidad nos dice cuál es la
proporción que es menor que punto 57
desviaciones estándar por encima de la
media 0
7.157 o lo que es lo mismo si las
estaturas realmente tienen una
distribución normal el 71 punto 57 por
ciento de los estudiantes tendrán una
estatura menor que la de daniel así que
la respuesta a la pregunta es 0.7 mil
157 y nos piden la respuesta con cuatro
cifras decimales que es lo que hicimos
aquí y con esto terminamos